[Music]
right now though let's check in with ted
get a look at our forecast because we're
heading into some of the warmest
temperatures we've seen so far
yeah we haven't reached 100 degrees yet
officially dee so could we reach it this
week we've been eyeing on this forecast
on whether that can actually happen
not quite there today and we're okay
with that a lot of us are with that
right clear skies
of course temperatures in the high 80s
like we've been pointed out to you
earlier still
right near average a live look right now
from alaska corporate camp look at the
real there
denver 41 degrees the high for the day
today somebody tell denver it's may okay
41 they actually had some snow on the
outskirts of denver you believe
unseasonably cold
and they had some showers 87 here that
puts us right near average sunny
and warm we're going to put that on
social media for you to share
with all your friends and family 88
degrees sky canyon the same goes for
centennial hills 84 for
spring valley 87 north las vegas the
east side coming in at 88 there for
southern highlands and 88 for whitney
ranch 88 henderson 85 for southern
highlands and same goes
for anthem at this six o'clock hour 86
in prep right now
82 indian springs 88 for mesquite and
laflin coming in
at 95 degrees now here's our doppler
network clear skies
not going to get anything here we had
some snow showers up there in utah
that's now moved off towards the east
we stay dry the big story of course is
going to be our temperature trend two
things we're going to talk about
the heat and the wind first the heat
look at this coming close to 100 degrees
thursday and friday we may not reach it
officially but that could change with
later updates
weather updates so we'll see if that
changes and we do reach our first 100 of
the year officially
65 overnight clear and nice look for
light winds overnight
good to see that 93 for tomorrow sunny
and hotter for tomorrow remember
only in the 80s today 88 is where we
should be we'll be reaching in those 90s
for tomorrow
here's your eight on the eight forecast
looks like this guy can just change on
so it's going to be windy friday and
also saturday so both of those days
we're going to up the winds again on
friday now
and you'll notice breezy winds after
that so temperatures will go up
drop them back down to the high 80s and
then warm up again early on
next week that is your most accurate
forecast here on eight news now here's
something i don't typically do
i'm gonna send it over to chris and
sportswear hopefully
we're talking the a's here right that's
right ted thank you very much